tour de france cycliste sauf accident
incident on connaît son vainqueur pour
la sixième fois ce sera l'américain
lance armstrong la 18e étape emmène
aujourd'hui les coureurs entre annemasse
et lons le saunier la caravane va donc
traverser le jura et la localité plus
précisément de château-chalon le berceau
du célèbre vin jaune lance deux chefs
fredericton il n'est pas à l'abri d'un
orage le savagnin pourtant sans ce
cépage jurassien pas de château chalon
le seigneur des vins jaunes
c'est au pied de ces falaises calcaires
où domine le village d'une non qu'on
trouve ce vignoble lui seul a droit à
l'appellation dans quelques semaines si
le ciel le permet les grains vont
prendre la couleur bronze doré difficile
de faire du château chalon chaque année
sans le bon dosage entre sucre et
acidité pour que le raisin très bon
équilibre alors on fait ça que les
volumes des très bonnes âmes et les
années bien ensoleillé des années
humides
on ne peut pas faire besoin pour cette
année là la france pour y arriver
puisque on a une belle récolte c'est
prometteur suffit que le soleil soit pas
avec nous ce commandant parce que
l'heure des vendanges à sonner un peu
tardivement cette année en raison du
temps selon la coutume des bandes
joyeuse en costumes des traditions s'en
sont allés donner le premier coup de
ciseau sous l'oeil patients des
attelages les grappes se sont amoncelées
jusqu'à la nuit dans les caissettes pour
être conduite au pressoir du domaine et
simon entrons à la mine des premiers
buveurs
ils se les sont voir les jolis vins
rosés d'arbois les solennelle vin jaune
les curieux brin de paille interdiction
d'ouvrir ses fut pendant six ans seule
solution pour ce viticulteur écouter
pour contrôler le niveau un voile de
levure protège de l'oxydation et
engendre un phénomène naturel mais
mystérieux au fil des années le niveau
diminue diminue des niveaux diminue
jusqu'à parfois représenté que la moitié
du togo pourquoi nuit
abbas et la phénomène c'est le phénomène
de ce produit de ce vin qui fait que
healy s'évapore c'est ce qu'on appelle
la part des âges dans d'autres régions
nous les enjeux sont très gourmands
puisque les consomment la moitié du fus
et cie les anges ne s'en mêle pas trop
il restera une bouteille d'un format
particulier avec un vin de garde ou de
noix qui se conservera peut-être un
siècle
enfin si le ciel ne nous tombe pas sur
la tête